Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
What you see here is a bunch of vector images.
Vector images are not like most images that
you see on the internet, those are raster
images.
Those are like photos, and are made of pixels,
while vector images are not made of pixels,
they are made of shapes.
These vector images have lots of advantages,
for instance, they have really small file
sizes, can be zoomed into as much as we desire
and things don’t get pixelated.
And hence, vector images are really well suited
for logos, maps, user interface icons, and
more.
Now, if we wish to, we can convert vector
images into raster images, so the shapes will
become pixels, this is easy, but here is the
problem.
If we do it once, there is no going back.
Or at least, not easily.
This method promises to make this conversion
a two-way street, so we can take a raster
image, a photo if you will, and work with
it as if it were a vector image.
Now what does that mean?
Oh boy, a lot of goodies.
For instance, we can perform sculpting, or
in other words, manipulating shapes without
touching any pixels.
We can work with the shapes here instead.
Much easier.
Or, my favorite, perform painterly rendering.
Now what you see here is not the new algorithm
performing this.
This is a genetic algorithm I wrote a few
years ago that takes a target image, which
is the Mona Lisa here, takes a bunch of randomly
colored triangles and starts reorganizing
them to get as close to the target image as
possible.
The source code and a video explaining how
it works is available in the video description.
Now, let’s see how this new method performs
on a similar task.
Oh yeah, it can start with a large number
of different shapes, and just look at how
beautifully these shapes evolve and start
converging to the target image.
Loving it.
But that’s not all.
It also has a nice solution to an old, but
challenging problem in computer graphics that
is referred to as seam carving.
If you ask me, I like to call it image squishing.
Why?
Well, look here.
This gives us an easy way of intelligently
squishing an image into different aspect ratios.
So good.
So can we measure how well it does what it
does?
How does it compare to, for instance, Adobe’s
state of the art method when vectorizing a
photo?
Well, it can not only do more, but it also
does it better.
The new method is significantly closer to
the target image here, no question about it.
And now comes the best part: it not only provides
higher-quality results than the previous methods,
but it only takes approximately a second to
perform all this.
Wow.
So there you go, finally, with this new technique,
we can edit pixels as if they weren’t pixels
at all.
It feels like we a living in a science fiction
world.
What a time to
be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!